欢迎收看
歌有仇必报的教学单元
我们的小歌专门来教大家看筹码
这一集我们要颠覆你的一个观念
很多人喜欢什么
喜欢大的
玩大的
可是在投资市场不是越大越好
很多的商品就是因为它太大了
它太贵了
根本没有人想交易
或是对散户来说
遥不可及
你这家公司就会
公司再棒
我也不會投資你
因為股價都太高了
好 所以事實上
市場上有很多微型商品
小型商品
為什麼小哥要叫小哥
不叫大哥呢
因為小的常常會比較好玩
小的也比較多人陪你一起玩
所以今天我們就要教大家
如果你小資想要用槓桿
其實很多人都會問說
我小資好像只能買零股
現在不止了
不是買零股而已
小资也可以买个股旗
小资甚至可以买海外旗
如何用小钱放大杠杆
又不会让你的风险太过超过
今天会来教你这些小型微型商品
怎么会想到小型微型
你平常都是讲大的
因为有些大的股票
第一个它的成交量或者是造势都会变差
对啦
一张那么贵100万对不对
因为通膨下去对不对
你的錢要留下來吃麵吃飯
通膨受害股就是高價股
真的 你看很多股王都腰斬
通膨都是這樣 股王先腰斬再說
為什麼要玩小型
就是大家錢變少
大家錢變少
大型那邊都沒有成交量
所以我們今天從白天交到黑夜
白天交到黑夜
白天的小型股
還有黑夜 因為晚上
因為有很多人他上班
不能下單
他只能在下班的時候下單
那錢又不多
錢不多
我們今天就介紹微型商品給他
微型商品
比小型還更小
微型
這個對大家很重要
因為小哥講了
可能今年很多人的錢都縮水了
或者是很多剛進市場
他覺得他的錢不夠
像我昨天就有回答一個聽眾朋友
在我Podcast
他說他的信用額度才3萬
3萬到底可以買什麼股票
他就問了我一堆零股的問題
現在也許不是零股
可以考慮用小型的期貨
對啊 因為他3萬塊買零股
他還必須做好資金配置
不能單壓一檔
所以他每一檔只能壓3000
壓3000 然後今天大漲一趴
大賺了30塊
這可能就沒有感覺了
所以當錢不多的時候
其實我們說當你錢不多
你可以開一點槓桿
好
當你錢很多
不要 拜託
然後也快退休了
那你就不要開槓桿了
領利息就好了
好
那最近就是因為通膨
通膨壓力還有升息
那升息導致大家錢又不多
那這怎麼樣妥善布局投資市場
因為投資成本增加資金縮水下
我們就要去尋找
投資成本低而穩健的標的
你找到這些標的之後
你就可以開一點點槓桿來玩
那第二呢
這些小型的這些期貨商品
它可以讓你靈活運用資金
因為你就不用拿那麼多的錢
來當保證金
那你就可以做好資產的配置
還可以分批布局
有的人錢不多
我說小哥這檔股票是怎樣
我說這檔你可以分批布局
可是小哥我只有一口的錢
它的佈局點就比較難做了
現在有小型的
它一口就可以改變做20口
就蠻好的
第三我們在慎選標的
今天會跟各位講一些比較穩定的標的
這些穩定的體質穩健
可以靈活配置
流動性加
這些你的交易就會更靈活
好
首先我們 先來看第一種
先從白天的來看
白天的
白天的 最近白天的小型期貨
成交還蠻大的
為什麼 因為最近大家錢比較少
像小型台紙 對 小台
你假如認為說這個台紙還不錯
會往上漲 你就可以來買小台
那小台呢 小台
這個一個跳動值是50塊
這跳一點是50塊
像錄影的今天 漲了300點
300點這一口做多的話就賺了1萬5放空就賠1萬5所以都有它的獲利跟風險在小型期貨有像小型台紙
還有小型電子
小電子
還有小金融
小金融
連金融也有
小金融它的保證金只要1萬9而已
不到2萬
超便宜
那現在這個小金龍它的指數
已經到了1600點
1600點 所以相當於是
它一點就有250塊的價值
那1600點乘以250
是多少你知道嗎
40萬
40萬的部位
對
等於2萬塊的保證金有40萬的部位
對 不到2萬塊有40萬的部位
像今天的小金龍
它漲了2%
對
你知道40萬的2%是多少嗎
8000塊
你看看你今天花不到2萬塊
賺8000
輸贏
假如你做多的話賺8000
放空就賠8000
放空就賠滿多的
所以這個槓桿算滿大的
槓桿有到20幾倍
對
好
那這個指數型期貨有小型
個股裡面也有小型
個股也要小型
因為有些高價股
高價股嘛
你買一口是兩張高價股
也是蠻恐怖的
像之前的大立光
大立光之前還漲到6000塊
現在比較便宜 只剩2000
只剩2000 一口兩張
那也要400萬的部位
那也很恐怖
所以像大立光它就有小立光
像大家很喜歡的台積電
也有小台積
因為台積電也已經500多塊了
也算貴了 放到500-600塊
他們看到成交都不錯了
就會發行小型的
那小台機也大家也滿喜歡玩的
那小型股票期貨呢
它的合約是一般股票期貨的
二十分之一
一般股票期貨呢
一口是2000股
小型股票期貨一口是100股
100股
那保證金呢
大概是
它的合約值
乘以13.5%到20.25%
所以槓桿呢
約莫是4到7倍
那小型股票起货
它的保证金有的很便宜
像小吻帽
保证金才2600多块
因为吻帽跌太多了
300多400跌下来的
对啊
那所以想要参与吻帽的涨跌
不用花到3000块
就可以来玩小吻帽了
那你玩这个你还不用担心
为什么
因为起货商他们有停损的机制
好主动帮你停损
怕你保证金不足
所以你要玩期貨
我們都說你的保證金不要放太多
我們有兩種說法
因為期交所官方說法
會希望我們叫大家保證金要放足
就不要小孩玩大車
可是小哥會告訴你
保證金放少一點
就快點看錯方向被斷頭出去算了
因為保證金放很多
有的人這樣子保證金
就一直凹單
10萬塊
10萬塊的保證金
他放了100萬進去
就後面把90萬都輸掉了
那反而不好
保证金你不要放太多
10万块你可能放个十几万
20万
那这时候呢
简讯会通知你
你做对还是做错
收到简讯就是做错了
因为收到简讯呢
追缴嘛
追缴啦
那追缴呢
你自己不砍
期货商也会帮你砍
这样子我反而觉得
比较稳健一点
等於期貨商幫你快速做停損
我覺得這個還蠻重要
就不會讓它變成槓桿
讓你的損失變得擴大很多
的確 好
那我們來看一下小型期貨的優點
這邊當然也要提醒觀眾
很多人一看到期貨
就把它當作是蛇蝦
妖魔化
槓桿開了當然風險就大
所以這一集教的就是
你要先理解這個槓桿風險之後
你再來學
那你既然要學
就不要一直覺得說
期貨是多妖魔
會害你傾家蕩產
自己風險控管要做好
對 其實害你傾家蕩產
都是你錄金錄太多
你不要錄那麼多錢就沒問題了
來看第一個 當然優點
第一個 交易成本很高
第二個 多空沒有限制
像最近很多股票都要強制回補
強制回補 除全息
還有金管會說限空令
對 限空令
那小型期貨它空就沒有限制了
那第三呢 這小型股票期貨還可以避開眷源不足
農券強制會不會困擾
那第四呢 小資主他就有機會參與高價股的行情
像小立光 小立旺 都還不錯喔那看第五個 交易價格比較親民保證金門檻就比較低比較低市場上就多了套利跟價差交易的機會我常常利用期貨來做套利
像最近的星象
星象它有四種期貨
為什麼呢
它不就是它也有小星象就對了
因為它除權了
所以有星象星象一
星象一它是4000股
星象是2000股
所以除全後還有星象1
對 中間有套利的機會
像小星象是100股
小星象1是200股
所以這盤中有時候你看到那個價格
價格你兩個對銷
它就可以套利了
可是星象的成交量好嗎
在除全息後幾天還不錯
最近的成交量就萎縮了
對啊 有時候高價股的問題就這個
好 那小型期貨的缺點
第一个 第一个 不管期货都有这缺点
保证金追缴的风险
我们一般讲 这保证金你遇到追缴
你就砍掉就好了
砍掉了 不要再凹了
不要入金
对 不要再凹了
入金是比较危险的
第二 部分商品流动性比较差
因为有些小型的期货
它的流动性比大型期货还来得差
为什么呢
一般不都是应该想说比较容易入门吗
因為它疊太多了
你說像穩帽那種
像穩帽
小穩帽它的成交量比大穩帽來的小
因為大家會覺得你看不見
穩帽這200多塊還叫我玩小穩帽
以為我買不起大穩帽嗎
因為玩大穩帽也沒多少錢
大概5萬多塊就玩得起了
所以有些玩小型的
因為你的手續會一樣多
手續會一口有的30 40
這很重要
手續會一樣
當然玩大的
因為很大的輸贏比較有感覺
但是那種股價動輒800-1000的
小型的通常流動性就好一點了
像大立光跟小立光
小立光的流動性比大立光好太多了
大立光幾乎是流動性非常差
那我們剛剛講完白天的
我們再講黑夜的
晚上來囉
晚上怎麼就變更小了呢
白天還比較大一點
晚上沒精神就更小了
變危險了
微博了
微博
最近不大能玩的一个商品
好 这个
晚上其实白天有
白天有
它是几乎24小时
海外期货
但是有些人他下班才能做交易
他就可以来做微型商品
海外期货我们首推CME
CME微型商品
这个它会降低参与的门槛
像以前
以前那個小納斯達克
小道琼 小S&P
你覺得它小
它一點都不小 你知道嗎
它的保證金有時候是四五十萬
四五十萬台幣
那一般人去玩小納
你玩小納 玩不起
那你可以玩什麼
可以玩微納
微納
微稻
對不對
那所以微型商品
它种类就多元
你就可以帮助投资策略跟避险布局
那微信商品如下
像微道 微纳 微S&P
微螺素都有
那你假如对金属有兴趣的
它有微黄
我们应该算微黄吧
微黄金
微黄标吗
微白银
还有迷你天然气
微欧元 微加币 微澳币
这些微型商品
微型商品通常都是十分之一
这个是要到海外
开海外期货账户
还是得开一下
在一般的国内期货账户
就可以开了
其实也蛮方便的
好
那我们来看一下微型期货
像这个维道琼
维道琼
道琼指数美国30党
知名男充股指数
维纳是纳斯达克100指数
美國100檔知名的科技股
維新S&P是美國500檔知名的
各產業指數的一些股票
維羅數2000就比較小型的股票
那這些我們來看一下
它的保證金
維到的保證金只要880塊美金
880塊美金就很便宜了
才2600而已 很便宜
維納的比較貴是1650塊
就成年大概4萬多塊
4萬多塊
所以你看小納要50萬才能玩的
對啊
所以小納是很貴的那維新S&P是這個1155塊30萬塊那維羅素呢很微很微不到2萬
2萬塊就可以了
交易時間呢
早上6點玩到隔天凌晨5點
難怪只能微實在太累了
中間讓你睡一個小時
通常我們都說
這個海棋不要玩太兇
玩到後面身體都不好
會壞掉
23個小時的交易時間
我看過很多玩海棋的
玩到後面眼睛都壞掉
因為我們平常做台紙的
到一點半就休息了
還可以等夜盤
夜盤3點才開始
最近夜盤也很活潑
做這種海外期貨的
一天整睡一個鐘頭
所以那非常累
所以為了身體健康著想
不要玩得太短線
那除了指數型以外呢
也有金屬型
像金屬型有微黃
微白
還有明影天然氣
那微黃呢
你看一下它的保證金呢
只要715塊美金
很便宜啊
2萬多塊而已
白銀比較貴
明影天然氣呢
是2500塊
那這些保證金呢
其實都不貴
好
那我們來看一下
微型商品的優點
是
第一個
用低成本可以放大收益
那第二个呢
这个保证金门槛低
可以分批进场
像小娜一口要50万
怎么分批啊
对啊
这身家也才50万而已
一口金就没了
好那第三呢
这投资组合多元
这就不止期货
不止股票了
对
它还有牵涉到贵金属商品种种
对啊
例如说你觉得黄金墙奶黄金
对
可是你又怕怕的空白银
可以做組合
好 那這個呢
多樣化就可以分散風險
那第四個呢
彈性操作策略
資金管理效率化
風險控管就比較精細
好 那布局策略呢
我們來看一下
策略怎麼做
好 第一個呢
短線交易
我們就可以用指數跟能源金屬來做
那你可以做一下判斷
第二個呢
中長期的波段交易
建議你可以用外匯
因為外匯呢
它會比較波段一點
那第三呢
这个益售美元汇率
市场避险情绪波动影响的时候
当重要数据公布的时候
像昨天晚上的CPI
一公布
喷出去
直线喷出
那这个人你就可以做当冲交易
有点像读法朔会
对
因为它波动很大
对啊
你低于
优于预期就喷出
高预期就跌爆
好
那我们举例来说
像之前
这黄金
对
各位你还记得
在之前乌二战争快要爆发的时候
还记得一句词语
枪声一响
黄金万两
就在这里
真的
乌二战争的枪声一响
黄金就喷出去
对
那这个喷出去之后
后面这个战刑
这战事比较
拖延
拖延久一点
再慢慢的又跌回来
对
那最近市场认为升息幅度
比较缩小
又慢慢的涨上去
因为可能跟美元是一个翘翘板
升级幅度低
美元就不会那么强了
黄金又变强了
对
黄金跟美元是走势是相反的
所以黄金涨跌
我们就看国际大势
你假如觉得下次
有哪个地缘政治
又出了问题的时候
那这时候你就可以靠
买黄金来获利
那微型黄金就是一个不错的商品
好
所以小哥今天又小又微
小的呢
看白天
微的可以看晚上
晚上的世界有时候更丰富
不过要开一个海外期货账户了
当然你会问
今天的荣耀班要教什么呢
当然荣耀班都是教
小哥最近在关注的商品
而且会告诉你
这个商品比较仔细的操作方式
所以记得加入荣耀班
接收更detail
更仔细的教学
好
今天非常谢谢小哥
白天晚上全都照顾到
也是照顾小资族的荷包
但是赵华一样
风险提醒
这一集教的是期货商品
期货商品的问题
它的风险不在于
这个买卖会失血很大
而是在于你要懂得它的杠杆
它杠杆本来你就要做好部位的控管
因为毕竟是用小钱玩大部位
所以小哥也教了保证金不要放太多
一旦有停损的问题立刻出场
风险控管好
这个商品很值得您学习
尤其是小资族的福音
希望今天的歌有仇必報
對您的投資有幫助
我們下次再見了
拜拜